[Music]
imagine you were out in public and you
found yourself injured maybe you're in
an accident and couldn't move or someone
had mugged you and in the ensuing
scuffle you'd ended up getting hurt
laying on the cold filthy concrete of
the sidewalk in desperate need of help
what could be the one thing that might
make you feel even the slightest bit
better something the very sight of would
be enough to tell you everything was
going to be okay the flashing lights
drawing closer accompanied by the sound
of tires on the road and a wailing siren
all signs that an ambulance is on its
way but what if the ambulance that came
to assist you ended up making you feel
far worse than you were before and
leaving you with injuries unlike
anything you'd ever seen
what if it wasn't an ambulance at all
that came to help you what if you were
found by scp-4419
instead jeremy had been having a
somewhat normal day until his accident
work had been another shift of long
arduous hours spent behind his desk five
o'clock finally rolled around he grabbed
his bag and punched out if he'd maybe
left a few minutes later he might have
gotten away unscathed instead of getting
caught in the mad rush of people leaving
work jeremy usually took the back
streets and avoided main roads as a
shortcut to get home there was less
traffic even during the rush and that
made crossing the streets safer usually
he had been looking the other way when a
car came speeding down the mostly empty
side street the driver had slammed the
brakes but only too late knocking jeremy
down winded he collapsed unable to stand
as the force of the impact had broken
his leg the driver and a few nearby
onlookers huddled around germany as he
lay there with his injury suddenly the
noise of an ambulance caused the other
pedestrians to mostly disperse still
trying to catch his breath in the last
moments of his fading consciousness the
last thing he remembered seeing were a
pair of figures they had jostled rather
aggressively through the crowd reaching
down to lift jeremy up and shoved him
into the emergency vehicle they were
considerably rude for medical
professionals nobody around wanted to
argue with them most would even go so
far as to call them hostile but that was
nothing compared to the horror that
awaited him when he reopened his eyes
laying back on the road where he'd been
found his body had been rearranged he
barely recognized it as his own it was
like he had been turned into some
grotesque animal made using human parts
his arms and legs had been rearranged to
protrude from his torso in an unnatural
configuration what felt even worse was
that his fingers toes hands feet they
all still worked all jeremy could do was
scream until he slipped back under a man
turned into something else entirely bad
days can happen to the best and worst of
us and sometimes those bad days can
spiral into very very bad nights mike
had been having a night like that
earlier that day he'd lost a fair sum of
money at the races gambling was one of
his many vices as was alcohol and to
commiserate his loss mike had hit the
bar unfortunately his already foul mood
was nudged into full-blown temper when
another patron accidentally bumped into
him the ensuing bar fight was a complete
disoriented drunken mess of glasses
being smashed and fists thrown one
managed to connect hard with mike's jaw
breaking it and leaving him sat on the
sidewalk in pain cop cars had shown up
officers breaking up the ruckus and
paramedics arriving to treat the more
badly injured patrons it was then that
two paramedics silently walked up to
mike and grabbed him by both arms as
much as he tried to pull away from their
forceful grip his arms were covered in
bruises and cuts from the glass their
fingers dug in honing in on those
painful wounded spots so that mike could
really feel his own injuries as they
pulled him up against his will trying to
verbally protest only hurt his jaw
further meaning he could barely call for
help as he was bundled into the back of
an ambulance doors slamming shut behind
him the next morning introduced mike to
a whole new and far grizzlier definition
of the word hangover one of the staff
who worked at the bar found him just
waiting outside when she came up to open
for business a few days later sitting
out front mike had been left in the
gutter although it took the bartender a
moment to notice just what was wrong
with him and when she saw it in full she
screamed instead of mike's jaw being
fixed it had been wrenched open far
wider than natural it was locked in a
permanent gaping expression the sides of
his lips sporting splits that ran all
the way into his cheeks lodge between
both rows of mike's teeth fused to his
gums was a piece of glass too thick for
him to break to free his jaw or even
bite down on a mouthful of glass shards
and blood cuts lining the inside of his
cheeks fragments lodged inside his
tongue all of that might have been
preferable a mercy compared to what
actually happened the glass was keeping
his mouth stretched out stopping him
from speaking like a transparent gag and
as if not being able to speak or beg for
help wasn't bad enough anyone that
looked through that little window was
also offered a whole other horrific view
they could see mike's heart it had been
pulled from his chest and reattached at
the back of his throat still beating as
tears rolled down his face he couldn't
eat talk only breathe through his nose
and it hurt reg and lee had vowed when
they first got married to love each
other for better or for worse in
sickness and in health until death did
they part and death very nearly almost
parted them if given the choice between
dying together or suffering through what
ended up being done to them not even
their love for each other would have
made them want to stay alive the rain
was beating down on the windshield as
the couple drove home in silence they'd
had a big argument in fact it was small
in the grand scheme of their
relationship just a lover's quarrel in
that moment though it felt like the
biggest problem in the world as those
types of squabbles often do but it would
have seemed quaint compared to the fate
that awaited both lee and her husband
that night visibility was poor the
headlights were doing little to help reg
see through the downpour or the dark he
found it so hard to see that he almost
missed their turn quickly wrenching the
steering wheel to try and correct the
mistake reg lost control of the car as
it slid on the slippery road flipping
sideways and rolling as the rain
continued to pour the airbags deployed
the force of being thrown around even
with her seat belt on caused lee to
suffer a number of broken ribs meanwhile
reggie's arm was broken when the
driver's side door connected with the
ground and dented inwards as the couple
were left buckled in their seats upside
down and both crying at the pain of
their injuries they spotted the
unmistakable silhouette of an ambulance
driving through the rain towards them
they were both so relieved that neither
one of them realized they hadn't called
the emergency number yet although the
rain had long since stopped by the time
lee woke back up the storm was just
beginning her head was spinning
everything was sore and aching she had
expected to be in a hospital maybe with
reg in her bed beside her both of them
recovering but alive at least pushing
herself up by her cut bloody hands lee
could feel something heavy behind her a
weight on her back like having a
rucksack strapped to her only it was
harder to move
almost the same mass as a person
slowly looking over her shoulder lee
screamed when she saw the flesh of her
back had been fused to regis their skin
melted and stuck together like candle
wax each of them unable to pull away
without the pain of feeling like they
were being ripped apart to make matters
worse lee had undergone
other
modifications talk about in sickness or
health living alone rodney was
relatively content with his life since
retiring he'd been able to spend his
twilight years appreciating the little
things spending most of his time out in
the garden tending to his flowers and
occasionally enjoying the company of his
adult son unfortunately with old age
comes the increased risk of health
problems and to say rodney had himself
more than his fair share of heart
difficulties or a bum ticker as he
called it was an understatement while
out in his garden rodney suffered a
violent heart attack and collapsed
wheezing and struggling to breathe
luckily his son keith was in the house
at the time he witnessed his elderly
father dropped to the ground and ran out
to help him calling for an ambulance as
he tried to calm rodney down the
emergency services seemed to arrive much
quicker than keith had been expecting a
pair of paramedics rushing through the
house to lift his dad away what struck
him as strange was neither one would
tell keith which hospital they were
taking his dad to and they outright
refused to let him ride in the back of
the ambulance to keep rodney lucid and
reassure him that he was in safe hands
when keith went to climb into the back
one of the paramedics pushed him by the
chest with enough strength to knock him
over as he pulled himself off the
concrete the rear door slammed shut and
the ambulance sped away to god knows
where with rodney in the back after a
few days of hearing nothing keith had
already tirelessly been calling every
hospital in the area to ask if his dad
had been admitted none of them had seen
rodney and his worried son had just been
about to call the police to file a
missing person's report when his elderly
father appeared on the doorstep
immediately keith drove his dad to the
emergency room trying to explain what
had happened with the strange ambulance
while the hospital maintained that it
wasn't one of theirs they admitted
rodney and gave him a full examination
only to find something that would turn
the stomachs of the world's most
seasoned doctors rodney had more than
one heart someone had given him not just
a spare but 11 additional hearts they
were stuffed between his natural organs
like too many books squeezed together on
a shelf and not one of them was beating
they were causing far more harm than
good rodney's insides were riddled with
these foreign bodies that were stopping
his lungs from fully inflating resting
on his stomach and wrecking havoc with
his bodily functions upon discovery of
these extra hearts rodney was rushed
into the operating theater with his son
nervously pacing in the corridor outside
sadly a doctor would soon appear to tell
keith that the moment the surgeons
removed one of the additional hearts
rodney's old bum ticker had finally
given out sometimes as sad as it may be
to reconcile with tragedy strikes one
night a fire broke out in a crowded bar
leading to a whole host of people
suffering severe burns and requiring
urgent medical attention what they
received instead was far more brutal and
barbaric joyce had been in the bar when
the alarms started to ring nobody knew
what had started it only that they
needed to evacuate but it didn't take
the flames long to reach the alcohol
behind the bar and before long the whole
place was ablaze everyone panicking and
barging past each other to get out once
free of the searing heat swapping it for
the biting cold of the night air the
commotion didn't seem to end someone
near her pointed to an ambulance that
had just arrived and a duo of paramedics
that were manhandling some of the more
badly burned bar patrons forcing them
into the back of their vehicle along
with about six others joyce marched up
as the group protested how the injured
drinkers were being treated when the
paramedics refused to stop things got
uglier the ensuing brawl left joyce in
the other six people with skull
fractures rather than just leave them
behind the paramedics grabbed them too
joyce was pushed into an already
overcrowded ambulance there were 26
people crammed in their total including
her 19 of them had nasty burns on their
skin wounds that were only made worse by
being packed together in such a tight
space and jostled around as the
ambulance drove away there were no sign
of the missing 26 bar patrons for around
a week the families of those that had
disappeared after the fire urged the
police to keep searching for them with
no bodies recovered at the scene by
firefighters nobody had a clue where the
group had gone joyce's partner al even
printed off missing flyers and handed
them out to anyone who would take them
they also happened to be the caretaker
of a local community center and after
another day of worrying tirelessly about
joyce al moped back there to clean and
lock the place up what they found
waiting for them was like something out
of an old horror b movie or something
found in the deepest parts of the ocean
filling one of the rooms of the
community center was a huge watery mass
it wasn't pure liquid although al first
mistook it as the result of a leaking
pipe the mass was fluid it twitched and
shivered whenever they reached out to
touch it almost like a living thing or
what was left of a few living things say
26 bar patrons melted down and reduced
to a collective liquid mass now you'd
think having an accident out in public
would be as bad as things got but that's
nothing compared to being injured in the
line of duty right in the middle of a
war zone that's what happened to private
jackson while he and his squad were out
on a routine patrol in afghanistan a
group of enemy insurgents ambushed the
united states as soldiers during the
ensuing firefight private jackson
sustained a severe gunshot wound leaving
him bleeding out his comrades had called
for a medical evacuation and were
expecting a us army helicopter to arrive
at any moment what none of them had
expected was a city ambulance driving
towards them across the battlefield as
if it was the most normal sight on earth
already suspicious of the approaching
vehicle private jackson's fellow
teammates raised their weapons at the
approaching paramedics despite the
soldiers demands for them to identify
themselves neither one of the ambulance
attendants seemed to pay them much mind
grabbing private jackson and dragging
the wounded soldier towards the vehicle
he called to the rest of his squad
wanting to be let go having no idea
where he was about to be taken or why
the commanding officer barked at the
pair of emts warning if they didn't
release private jackson then his men
would open fire still the paramedics
didn't seem to be listening just as they
threw jackson into their ambulance and
climbed into the cab at the front the
other soldiers opened fire squeezing
their triggers bullets were spat from
their weapons riddling the metal sides
of the vehicle as it began to drive away
siren blaring and lights flashing every
shot that connected with the ambulance
seemed to cause it to leak of viscous
black fluid like an oil but despite this
it did little to deter the ambulance
from driving away with jackson captive
in the back after being successfully
extracted from the battlefield the
remainder of the squad were airlifted
back to safety arriving back at their
nearby base the following day each one
of them were solemnly silent all of them
were confused as to how an ambulance had
even appeared in the desert out of
nowhere and disappeared without a trace
but even more so they were concerned for
the life of their kidnapped comrade
however they wouldn't have to wait long
as arriving at their barracks revealed
the grim grotesque fate of private
johnson he was on the walls as in
all over the walls his body had been
dissolved somehow broken down into
little more than a thin bloody paste
that had now been smeared over the
interior of the barracks looking out at
his former squad from the liquefied
remains was a single human eyeball
private jackson's eye wide with horror
at what had been done to him
scp-4419 known to some by the nickname
of the butcher's chariot is still out
there at present it is unknown who or
indeed what performs the horrific
mutilations on its victims or even why
it could be that scp-4419
if it has a consciousness could be
trying to help those it abducts but
lacks the correct medical understanding
of how to do so then again it could
simply just be cruel torturing and
deforming people unfortunate enough to
need emergency medical attention given
how sporadically this anomalous
ambulance can appear and disappear at
the site of any medical emergency
anywhere on the planet there's little
the foundation can do other than stay
vigilant and pick up
scp-4419's patience after it has
mutilated them or rather they can pick
up whatever's left of their victims now
go and check out
man
scp-2086
bus for another anomaly that at first
takes the shape of an ordinary vehicle
but soon becomes something far more
terrifying and after keep an eye out for
scp-973
chased by smokey for more horror
stalking the roads